[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy I spoke at Stanford University
recently and Stanford administrators and
leftist students made sure that as few
people as possible heard me now in the
coming of the Third Reich historian
Richard J Evans explains how in the
early days of National Socialist Germany
stormtroopers Nazi Brownshirts organized
campaigns against unwanted professors in
the local newspapers and staged mass
disruptions of their lectures and here
we are again in the days before I
arrived on campus the student runs
Stanford daily and Stanford Review
published article after article
denouncing me in the most lurid terms it
was claimed that I give license to the
oppression of Jews and that Muslims at
Stanford were endangered by my work it
was charged that I have incited a mass
murderer and approved of restricting the
right to vote my work was characterized
without any specific examples of being
not only inaccurate but also
inflammatory offensive hateful and
dishonest but that was nothing compared
to what Stanford administrators had
ready for the event itself Nancy how the
associate dean and director of student
activities and leadership and snehal
naik the assistant dean and associate
director of student activities in
leadership made sure that the hall was
packed with students who had no
intention of attending the lecture at
all they were only there to sabotage the
event by denying seats to people who
actually wanted to attend they even kept
out some members of the college
Republicans the group that was
sponsoring the event the fascist
students stood up and walked out after
just a few minutes of hearing me then
after the walk out how an IKE refused to
allow in people who actually wanted to
attend and denied repeated requests that
they'll open the doors they also refused
to allow the young America's Foundation
to stream the event clearly because they
knew what was in the offing and did not
want video going out
that would show just how much Stanford
has deteriorated and how opposed it is
to free discourse I had no contact with
how Mike greeted me however with great
warmth and affability and actually said
we're glad you're here oleaginous
insincerity used from his every pore the
lying his unctuous demeanor he was so
unyielding however that at the end of
the event when college Republicans who
have been bullied and victimized by
Stanford administrators all through this
process of having me speak and
egregiously and repeatedly smeared in
the Stanford daily and other student
republication z-- asked him if some of
the members who had not been allowed in
could now come in for a group photo he
refused to allow even that at that point
I asked him if he had always been a
fascist or had just become one recently
he looked embarrassed and he should be
embarrassed videos showed Nancy how
happily circulating among the Stanford
students walking out of the event and
patting them on the back and chatting
with them she appears later again
grimacing as I criticized Stanford
President Mark Tessier Levine and
Provost persist drell for failing to
teach the defib or defend the freedom of
speech and for acting to crush
dissenting opinions with how
stage-managing the disruption of the
event this obviously it's clear now why
she refused to allow streaming she
didn't want her engineering of Stanford
students disrupting the event to be
caught on video but it was fascism has
no place on university campuses or at
least it shouldn't but thanks to
administrators such as Nancy Howe and
snehal Naik mark Tessier Levin and
Persis drell and so many others like
them all over the nation it is dominant
a sane university would fire these
administrators immediately however it is
likely that they are not responsible but
are just reflecting the zeitgeist and
maybe even executing orders from higher
up it is the president of Stanford
Tessier Levine and persists drell the
Provost who should be fired but it's
much more likely that they will be
lauded hailed and celebrated by their
peers for their denial of free inquiry
i'm roberts
sir
[Music]